it's being built as the world's largest
hot tub party at Circa Resort and Casino
we are joined today by Chase Baker who
is with Stadium swim it is Las Vegas's
only year-round pool Amphitheater thanks
for being here Chase appreciate you
coming yeah of course thank you so much
for having me really appreciate being
here as well sounds pretty cool big hot
tub party the world's largest and
there's an 80s thing to it right yes
absolutely so at Stadium swim we're
trying to promote and host the biggest
and absolute baddest parties in all of
Las Vegas this entire winter so winter
swim and Stadium swim we are hosting
tons of Signature Events like what you
mentioned our next signature event is
going to be the 80s uh heated pool party
and it is going to be located in stadium
swim which is the within the world
famous circle Resort and Casino and it's
going to be on January 6th from 4 to 9
p.m and like I said it's going to be at
Stadium swim 80s theme so you're going
to have the right colors and a lot of
throwback stuff absolutely so the gears
such as this that you're wearing that's
what I like that absolutely so we're
strongly encouraging guest to be able to
bring their 80s ski gear yeah um have a
great time and as far as the the party
wouldn't it tells we're trying to
overall incorporate the the ski lodge
experience and then instead of having
people go to the ski lodge we're trying
to bring the ski lodge experience to
them so over here we're having shot skis
as well as a winter swim
or winter themed drinks we also have a
bunch of gear to advertise as well such
as our Stadium swim beanies in order to
stay warm and then one of our greatest
things is our actually beautiful plush
robes right here and so they're for
purchase so if you don't necessarily
have that 80s ski gear yeah um with you
at the time you're more than welcome to
purchase these and the tickets for this
event are going to be
um as low as 15 and you just go I have
to go ahead to circlelasvegas.com and
that's where you can purchase your
tickets for this event so that's coming
up January 6th and then in February I
believe it's February 4th you have a
bikini competition is that right
absolutely yes so like I said multiple
Signature Events throughout the entire
winter and overall you can bring your
friends have a grand time as far as the
the bikini contest you know it's I do
have this don't necessarily have the you
know the polka dot bikini that's going
to look as good as this but yeah overall
it's just gonna be a grand time it's
definitely going to have the time of
your life and the winner gets money too
right yes absolutely so the cash prize
or not necessarily cash prize but the
overall prize is going to be ten
thousand dollars for the bikini contest
winner all right so to people who
haven't been to swim stadium tell them
what it's all about yeah of course so
it's all about just having a grand time
bringing you your friends your family
overall celebrating together we have
giant over 150 foot screen at which you
can watch any sort of sport on it's a
giant party atmosphere and it's the spot
to be during this winter love it Chase
thanks so much for being here today I
really appreciate it I want to tell
people more about this the 80s hot tub
party is happening at Stadium swim
inside Circa January 6th that goes from
4 to 9 pm if you want more information
as Chase said just go to
circularlasvegas.com